now
you are always out in the field uh with
these targets
and what was your you and your wife
worked together on a lot of these
operations right right
so where would your wife be during this
uh so the
there's multiple ways that we that we
consider the field the field is kind of
like a whitewash
term that comes from movies and books
technically there's there's forward
operating which means that you are
like in boots on the ground
working in some other place
right actually deployed to a foreign
location or
whatever to do your work right forward
operating and then there's
not forward operating there's just
deployed which could mean that you're
deployed to a protected
area like consider afghanistan you might
be forward deployed
into the hinterlands of afghanistan
living in a tent but you'll be deployed
to a military base that sits in
afghanistan
right both of those are technically
considered the field okay right you
could also be sitting back in virginia
waiting to be deployed or on a rotation
where you're going to multiple locations
and still technically be considered a
field officer even though you're sitting
in virginia
okay right so make sense yeah so from
that perspective my wife and i were
what's known as a tandem couple
we were always deployed together so we
would be in some
other location together usually in a
controlled safe
location whether it's an apartment that
we own or operate undercover
whether it's some kind of uh
government-controlled facility something
right we would be deployed together in
the field and then
i would operate forward and she would
operate from the field location she was
what's known as a targeter
should be on base basically yeah if you
yeah to use simple terms she would be on
some kind of home base whether that home
base is our apartment or that home base
is
her cover provider or that home base is
you know a controlled facility
okay that makes sense yeah did you was
that
were you receiving like any kind of
special treatment or is that something
that a lot of
couples would do in the cia work
together like that there's not a lot of
couples
in the cio that makes sense yeah there's
a lot of like there's a lot of divorced
couples at cia right
yeah i think we talked about that but
yeah so what ends up what the reason it
worked for my wife and i was because we
came from two different disciplines
my wife and i are total opposites we
talked about it with personality testing
right
um uh we've talked about it with like
with how we look at politics and how we
approach
problems of the world but my wife's
specialty was something known as
targeting my specialty was known was
known as operations human
operations targeters are basically like
superminds that can find and access
and come to conclusions about
individuals based on available
information
and then they can build a dossier they
can build a package
about a person that's so personal that
they can essentially hand it to an
operator
and the operator can go meet that person
and
feel like they've known them their whole
life wow that's a special skill
not only is it a special skill because
it takes intense determination
to find and dig through that much data
right because it's not easy to find that
much stuff about a person
but then also to be able to have the
analytical mind where you can take
12 people 12 potential targets and boil
them down to two good targets
right because every step of the way
you're looking at dozens and dozens of
people looking at all their profiles
looking at their work history looking at
their
network of connections looking at what
they have access to looking at whatever
you can find about their test scores or
their intelligence scores or their
performance in college or whatever else
boil it down to basically like here's
two good targets
you know go forth and conquer that's
what people don't know is that
like like case officers and ops officers
in the field the people that they make
movies about
we're like a dime a dozen it's not hard
to find people like us
right it's hard to find your targeters
your analysts your
imagery analysts those people that the
agency really protects
interesting yeah so that was i know my
wife's value
honestly i know my wife's value more
than she knows her own value
because of our core myers-briggs
personality that's so interesting
i love what you were talking about on
that uh that episode of your podcast
where you're talking about how you guys
are such opposites
and it it makes it turns you guys into
like a power couple because you guys
you succeed where she fails and your her
strong points are your weak points
um i can definitely relate to that with
my wife um
so how did the agency
you talked a little bit about how the
agency or your wife talked about how the
agency
changed her perspective it changed her
she grew up
being a very liberal and very uh
liberal family very a for you know
progressive family
and the agency changed her to more
center conservative
so i found that very very fascinating
yeah and at the risk of
i'm not going to speak for my wife but
what i will speak for is my experience
and what i've seen
in people like my wife it's not that the
agency
changes the way that you view the world
it's that the agency exposes you to the
real world
and once especially folks the farther
left
the farther liberal the farther
progressive they are
like in their world view the more
they're exposed
to the real world outside of the united
states
they're just faced with information that
makes them ask
very difficult questions about
themselves right so
for example one of the things that my
wife used to
just be really passionate about was
refugee affairs
she's like we need to take care of
refugees these people are coming from
horrible places they're relocating the
united states and then we're not doing
enough for them
like we we don't give them education we
don't give them you know
effective uh cultural training
to to a cultural relates into the united
states
or to assimilate into the united states
uh we need to do all this stuff
for for refugees this was her view prior
to the cia
correct because she was in she went to
law school to do refugee law
okay and then she worked in a non-profit
relocating refugees so she was very
passionate about it man it was like
it was something that was so important
to her that she had basically dedicated
her her core adult years to learning how
to take care of refugees was there an
experience that she had that made her
feel that strongly
um part partly was growing up as a third
country child because my wife was born
in venezuela
okay grew up in japan and then relocated
to the united states oh wow
and her parents are one venezuelan one
american her family is split venezuelan
and american and she survived like she
lived
and watched her family go through all
the chavez years and all the you know
the demise of venezuela from a first
world city to a third world city
or the the city of caracas in the
country of venezuela
so she's got reasons right but my point
is
once she actually started seeing the
world like once once she didn't just see
venezuela
japan and the united states once you
started seeing what life is like in
africa what life is like in southeast
asia
what life is like in latin america true
poverty
true corruption true genuine abuses of
human rights
right actual slave labor
all of a sudden her baseline for what is
unacceptable
shifted and it shifted a lot right
what she used to think was how are we
going to bring in refugees
and only give them 35 000 a year
and only give them a crappy one-bedroom
apartment for a family of three that's
such an abuse
and then she goes out into the real
world and she's like oh my gosh like
there are families
in china living in hutongs which are
just pieces of aluminum
leaning up against the wall and the only
thing they use for fire is their own
feces
and there's whole families generations
of families living together
in these hutongs and she's like that how
is that acceptable
so all of a sudden like that perspective
increased and that's not just unique to
her that's unique to everybody at the
agency
i was also fairly liberal going into the
agency coming out of the agency i was
like oh
what i need to protect what makes
america amazing
isn't all of our social welfare programs
what makes america amazing is our
surplus of
of income and our capital our ability to
generate
massive amounts of capital because just
a small fraction of that massive amount
of money
is what can fund a social welfare
program where in a foreign country
they're like the whole country might be
a social welfare program
because they don't have enough wealth to
just skim off a little bit
and because all of the money is going
into social welfare there is no money
that goes into infrastructure so nobody
has clean water
there is no money that goes into the
electrical power grid so there's
routine power outages right there's no
money to go into public health
there's no money that goes into whatever
else here
by making sure that our core bull market
succeeds making sure that rich people
have the capacity to make more money
bigger businesses more jobs right more
taxes
making sure they have that ability is
what funds everything else
and the thing that made it possible for
cia to go out there and be
the highest performing intelligence
agency in the world is because
it's got a [ __ ] ton of money why does it
have so much money
because we support this market we
support this this world
this economy that just drives to
encourage and
incentivize people to be more than they
have to be
right you want to be a if you want to be
a doctor that makes 25 000
a year you can go be a doctor in
mongolia right you can go be a doctor
and freaking most parts of europe you're
not going to make a lot of money as a
doctor
right you come here you make a bunch of
money you become a doctor
you start making millions of dollars a
year that's great for us
because the government's going to tax
you for like 38 of your net worth
sucks to be that guy right but you're
still making
10 times what you'd be making if you
were a doctor in france
or if you're a doctor in italy right
right so
like that's what makes the market work
and the fact that you can incentivize
those people by a
few percentage points of taxes right i
love that
i love the fact that we're making more
doctors more lawyers and more
billionaires than ever before
and that we're incentivizing people who
are coming out of college to pursue
those really difficult
it's not easy to build a business it's
not easy to become a doctor we're
incentivizing them
for like two percentage points of taxes
right like oh
we'll decrease your taxes from 38 to 36
and we won't tax capital gains like to
them
that's hundreds of thousands of dollars
potentially millions of dollars right
and all
of that money just goes right into the
united states tax base
that allows us to have roads without
potholes an electrical grid that runs 24
7 365 days a year
and clean water that literally comes out
of our toilet if we chose to drink it
right right
that's insane there's parts of the world
there's parts of the first world where
you can't trust the water that comes out
of a water fountain
like it's just we have it so good here
you don't realize it until you
start to travel and see the world
through the eyes of a spy
wow yeah so that's how she shifted
that's how
many of us shift because you start to
see
the real outside of america world
and you start to have a whole different
sense of your left and right boundary